this is my ford f-150 raptor and we're  gonna drive it back to bronxville  through the blizzard of 2015.  let's get one of these boxes for  stephanie rule  let's do this  so we have uh stocked up on everything  we need for the storm here we've got  uh pretzels we got blueberries we have  fiber one bars everything uh from water  to batteries to oranges to tennis balls  those are actually for steve but there's  nobody else here  gas stations are not packed people are  not lining up around the block with gas  cans nobody's preparing for the zombie  apocalypse it doesn't seem that bad it's  just snowing we've uh put 33 gallons of  gas into my big black behemoth here and  we're going to take it on my 17 mile  commute to work hopefully we make it  through snowpocalypse  the blizzard of 2015.  you